and it just gets really emotional you
know they're i i think i saw you crying
i did cry a couple times it touched me
in multiple ways during scene scenes
during action don't cry don't cry until
the end when the characters are crying
to let us know it's okay to cry in the
teeth yeah not until alpha cries
the order comes down from tom and
crying's cool man
you just look like a chunk
[Music]
what up reject nation greg and john here
today we switched sides oh no just gotta
mix it up on the side
we just saw top gun maverick you guys
know me i love me some tommy cruz if
there's one thing i know between john
and i i'm definitely a bigger tom cruise
fan generally yes in fact i would credit
you with making me a tom cruise fan and
really being my portal my gateway
people to tom cruise tom cruise converts
them into something else
guys if you could leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated here's the first
thing i think we should say you gotta
watch this in the theaters if you're
going to watch this watch it in the
theater from the biggest most clearest
screen possible or if you're a reaction
channel wait for it to come out on
streaming and react to it from your
computer you'll get views
get someone to shake your seat around
sometimes to make it feel more vital
like it's a d-box or something this was
so immersive and transportive i don't
think you would have to have seen the
first top gun film but you'd one million
percent appreciate this more if you have
seen the first top gun movie there's
going to be things that happen in here
that you just flat out you you won't
really care that much about unless
you've seen the first top gun film and
it takes place like i don't know what
was on top come out like 88 years ago
yep 88 years ago today what were you
1986. so like 45 years ago 400 years ago
so yeah um maverick is now in his late
70s
maverick is on his deathbed in an
aircraft yeah he just can't quit
he's going to fly
you need to go to the hospital you were
dying
your heart is failing and you're going
to crash to kill innocent pilots that's
what i do
and i'm going to go down the way i lived
i'm gonna switch between calling him tom
cruise and maverick maverick is uh he's
now gonna be the new top gun instructor
incredibly risky operation they have to
do so they bring in the best to train
this new crop of top of the top pilots
to go on this incredibly impossible
mission
you know when i was walking out this
movie i was thinking you know one title
you could have called this is maverick's
top gun
you know what i mean like he wrote and
directed it himself yeah you could
because it really is maverick's movie
and it really is tied into his both uh
journey since the past movie and his
journey past the point where we meet him
here it is it is as much as it is it
ensemble piece in ways like top gun it
is very focused in on the emotional core
of maverick yeah because maverick in
this movie without giving too much away
tom cruise gives an amazing performance
in this film that's one thing that
really dawned on me watching this was
like we all know that tom cruise loves
to commit to the stunts he loves to
commit to learning how to do things he's
never learned before in order to bring
it to the big screen but it's not just
watching a guy pull off cool action and
stunts he always brings his a game with
the performances like it seems like the
more invested he is in pulling that
realistic crazy stuff off of that makes
his performance better throughout
because there's a lot of just great
scenes of him having just dialogue
moments quiet moments dramatic moments
some of the times he's like really funny
in that sort of dry unexpected way you
don't see from tom cruise uh that often
like i forget tom cruise would be a
pretty funny guy this movie itself is
structurally very similar to the first
top gun movie except for some beats in
the finale like the finales when without
giving anything away the finale is when
it takes
like the finales it expands it opens up
the wings it's an amazing finale it's
not a repeat of act 3 of that movie
because this film structurally is very
similar yet i would also say that i only
saw top gun one for the first time a
couple months ago so i'm not like a big
fan i don't have this crazy nostalgia
for top gun watching this 40 minutes and
i'm like this one was way better than
the first one
we don't offend anyone but i was
watching it going this movie is much
better it just has much more of a heart
i take it really serious i get really
truly invested in the characters the
action is just beyond phenomenal i've
never admired aviation so much and i've
never wanted to not do aviation so much
at the same
this just looks like the most horrifying
plus you got lights going off and you
got things exploding and you retakes
that they said yeah this movie because i
had these guys really fly
and even though you know they probably
weren't flying at exactly the same
conditions it very much convinces you
that they are and they do build a pretty
strong ensemble based around that and i
think that's something this movie like
the original top gun obviously has it
has some amazing aerial sequences for
the time especially but this movie uses
that to make everything more tangible
and more visceral and then because of
that you appreciate just the value of
life that much more and that bolsters
the ensemble of characters i think well
i think the first top gun movie the kind
of vibe was bros yeah like bro rivalry
but because this is from maverick's
perspective now where he has become the
instructor one thing i admired about it
was it's one of those rare movies where
it seems like tom cruise is willing to
play a character of his age they
actually leaned into that specifically
as opposed to the mission impossible
films where i remember watching ghost
protocol and going kind of kind of aging
no one's talking about it
then you watch him here you're like he
looks amazing he looks amazing
especially everywhere all these young
people but everyone's pointing out he's
old yeah yeah totally and i mean they
use his growth it has a coming-of-age
quality even though you do meet maverick
at a point in his life when he is more
sage and has a bit more experience and
wisdom on him it's not this dark imagine
there was a bunch of top gun movies in
the 80s and this was the logan of the
top gun
yeah just a much more introspective
version of this guy he still has that
maverick ego and cockiness but much more
care and clearly has a lot of pain what
i loved about tom cruise's performance
was whatever that gap is you can feel
that tom cruise filled all that in and
that's the weight he's carrying in his
performance before watching this movie i
was mainly expecting to come out of here
going the flight and that's all amazing
you've heard a billion people say that
but a lot of credit goes to tom cruise's
amazing performance in this movie he
gives an incredible performance he
brought his 100 a game in terms of
acting and it is one of those you know
it is like a bro cry in a bro hug movie
but in a very different way from the
original and i like that tom older bro
looking after younger brothers exactly
trying to impart a little knowledge and
help the younger bro grow into the best
bro he can possibly be or she there are
female pilots as well in here by a
couple we mean one good character i like
to and it just gets really emotional you
know they're i i think i saw you crying
i did cry a couple times it touched me
in multiple ways during scene scenes
don't cry until the end when the
characters are crying to let us know
it's okay to cry in the teeth yeah not
until alpha cries
the order comes down from tom then
grinds cool
you just look like a chump there were
times i caught myself where i didn't
realize i was i was actually i might my
fist was clenched for a large portion in
so many of the sequences especially in
the finale nipple chills i was really
into it and i couldn't i couldn't tell
it was no jennifer connelly is a good
stand-in for someone pretty
there is some of that 80s cheese and i
and i i wouldn't say cheese in a bad way
there is some of that 80s pulpy
emotionality that i think really suits
the movie well and tempers it because
there is a soaring heart swell that i
think the original top gun does
encompass especially through the music
and the motifs of the iconic songs in it
and there is a love story at the core of
that and you have all these big
personalities of the pilots so there is
some of that cheese and i feel like some
of that comes in through jennifer
connolly because it is so kind of
idyllic the way that they capture that
relationship and that longing but i want
to stress i feel like it wouldn't be top
gun without that it's updated well
enough for today that it's not super
cheesy and it's not trying to emulate
the 80s it just feels like it's akin to
what came before it from the 80s i agree
no that's a great way to put it i mean
though i think kelly mcginnis was a
great character though in the first one
let's see i felt like kelly mcgillis and
that was in the 80s i thought she was a
like a great character and then here
jennifer connolly while i think jennifer
connolly and tom cruise have just a
natural great chemistry because clearly
their charisma bounces off of each other
i found myself going why is she like
nothing i don't like i don't understand
what her character is she's just idyllic
dreams yeah she really it starts
becoming like tone poems for her
it really does this performance we're
watching she's teaching him stuff and
she runs her own bar and things and it's
all idyllic i forget about you they try
to implement that thing of i might not
come back alive like i forgot you
existed she's out of the sunswept
montage set to saxophone music a little
bit but it does add again like a nice
element of heart even though she's not
as much
she is not as much of a character and i
and you can levy that as a great because
kelly mcgill is like is an actual
character in a different way the most
that jennifer connolly's character gets
is just like don't break my heart again
she a lot of smiling yeah the one who
surprised me is miles teller he plays
goose's son goose's son who's called
rooster
what yeah there's a theme i have a weird
relationship with miles teller every
time i watch miles teller in a movie my
first thought for like the first 10
minutes on screen is i bet this guy's a
real prick like that in real life that's
where i go my mind just goes i hate this
guy he's just such a snob and then
almost every movie i watch him in that's
my first reaction and then i'm like you
know this guy's a pretty damn good actor
that's a great miles teller always
winning me over he may move miles tell
her my mind just works that way with him
he especially at first you know it's
like it's been revealed that he plays
goose's son i started thinking like yeah
it was whatever halfway through like is
whatever but in the last half he does
something he rose to the occasion he's
he becomes like a really strong
character and a big heart so yeah guys
it's a really strong recommendation for
top gun maverick beautifully shot
wonderfully acted no action movie like
it other than the first top gun that
movie made tom cruise famous this is tom
cruise with power and here's how he's
going to produce this victory lap this
is like pretty meaningless
it's insane how they pulled this off i i
this is one of those movies as i was
watching it i was going i want to see
the making of this looks absolutely
terrifying to put your actors through
this had a big bleeding heart it had
incredible action sequences a great time
cruise performance a great ensemble and
it checked all the boxes i personally
would want out of a top gun movie while
also elevating that honoring it in a way
that's not obnoxious i i would
absolutely recommend seeing this on the
best possible screen all right guys we
will
see y'all soon